yep I can grapple dope I totally can do
this alright alright fly you fool don't
don't run me in the mouth don't remove
oh no wait
oh I'm below you don't lie you got this
good yeah just fly we're good
so glad I try this
all right there's the helicopters over
there let me I'll mark him yeah look at
tower we're on the map last time well
this is just one of the other quests
yeah yeah I mean there's a hut like a
helicopter hunting quest
all right well you want to lower me over
here oh you do two helicopters yep
oh good I'm gonna get down music I can
lowered it no I'm good okay up there
we're good that was free oh [ __ ] no no I
meant a lot I meant to lower I meant to
Lord that the hell are you alive can you
revive me where are you as the
helicopter fell right where you jumped
off where I don't see your body no all
right where's your body it's gone so I'm
just recently okay I had some wolf dude
over here I'm right here alright that
was awesome I'm so glad I was looking up
where you did that
I cannot walk into this flaming building
it's a problem are on fire fire so
contagious I get that
moving reach Cooper cabin who's behind
us F there's the bad guys behind us wait
get him get him helicopter let's chase
after okay you're gonna try shooting out
of the helicopter if you don't mind
flying somebody spotting us who sees us
that's the same one try pulling him next
to him I can't use it for sure we'll
just do likely the weapon will just land
on top of the hill the carpet man I
think you tried that you mostly just
died
okay the cameras stash should be
somewhere there's a Colt patrol headed
your way we got this fine let me land
over someone cars around where whatever
all right
- we'll definitely see outside the cabin
I got it
[Music]
now we're looking for got it
what's going on up here it seems real
smoky and I'm on fire
alright next cabin yeah hey we don't
lose a helicopter to fire yeah we're
good on fire
alright let's do this alright you fly
okay doing a hang yeah yeah
just look up a beam grapple alright go
yeah let's go onward tell me Chico's
trees
okay stop stop believe this already
would you give me what I stopped I just
see you fly up in front of me yes
stop
Hey nope what happened okay dunno just
heavier ya pray here can you lower into
the rooftop hey just slow slow a good
par get up here dear
are you lowering hope I see you
I've never get roadkill somebody in
front of you
hey officiating at me we gonna land a
helicopter somewhere I can have it again
now you got this
founder yet the cache of the tracker
that will cause a feedback loop on your
radio if you get close they probably
hate it underground definitely wouldn't
keep it in the cabins
Oh
is it over here
I see it mine shaft over here like an
outhouse
I think I see it if you come towards me
right here where the helicopter is now I
see you
all right
all right nice job on to the next one
okay
good
all right well you already here yep
where this word was on the marker okay
again there's a called patrol headed
your way
same one up cuz hope that's all right in
front of you they're all coming around
you open the shoot at me
hang on I gotta land somewhere else and
then take it from behind there all right
over the top of you right now so if you
dare hole coming out of there
this gets my here again
[Music]
[Music]
alright where's helicopter we're good
where are you where refers me and those
guns for hire are fishing chaps
alright good you it's at the end of the
mission
no there's still one more
good are you in Yemen behind you
I'm gonna let a foot would do something
stupid I'm curious what's gonna happen
what do you have a monitor
oh just please don't do that stop
hey I got you on camera again just ever
ever this for a second are they running
on the left side can you shoot at them
I can unless you have to come
all over on
I'm gonna get it let me get ahead of
them yeah head of once again enough I
supposed to kill him
yeah don't have a you have an RPG can I
blow them up yeah you have to turn to
your left so I can actually see them and
not shoot around how we got there yeah
so you have to you have to get the door
facing them okay and hotel
lost that work yep that works okay we're
down
Killick Slams
where are they he's in the water alright
and forget it I blew him into the water
with a rocket
okay I'm gonna grapple cuz it's just way
more fun
good all right good
he'll treat oh I can actually get into
the helicopter do
all right here we go
why Oh God
nice and quiet oh yeah that's why it
like I said before if they spot you
they'll kill our people so keep out of
sight there's a drain pipe nearby you
can use to sneak up on
they killed two hostages oops
hostage somewhere peggy's find us we
don't stand a chance
but if our guys don't give up the
location they'll be tossed off that
cliff oh I didn't get out of South of
you
perfect
careful now roadblock up in
you get him you're gonna take some
landings
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
we lost some good people today Rick you
did the best you could
helping us take care of our own is gonna
have a big impact on morale maybe even
get some more folks to join up - yeah I
knew it Tammy was wrong about you
congratulations you're one of us now if
you've got time I got more work don't
see me in the Wolf's den when you're
ready we're still get on the helicopter
kept asking me to sabotage it they're
calling in chopper convoys to patrol for
whitetails swivel to the sky yourself a
rocket
I can't shoot from here all I can use is
this sidearm
yeah I won't let me change the gun that
I'm in here nice all right I guess
they're supposed to hunt helicopters
yeah
[Music]
okay marked it we're gonna go after
off to your right side
sucks they only let me use this pistol
maybe I'll bring you up you can get the
pilot
got one
Adam nice I think that's all three of
them although I think we're about to
explode
he's right in front of us he's on the
ground
[Music]
I move watch the money that's I got some
life in it actually let me try to hop in
the back and see if I'm in the back if I
guess which weapon Oh
ah yes in the back I can absolutely put
open
helicopter to our right
[Music]